不要开这样的口，
建议人家离婚，
就建议她保护好自己的财产就很好了，
守住自己的存款，
观察男方的负债，
跟男方的经济往来的时候一定要特别的注意。
是我想咨询的事情，
是我闺蜜的一件事儿，
她跟她老公是8月份里挣的，
但她老公跟我对象是朋友关系，
所以我们有一些共同的朋友圈，
最近呢，
我是知道一些她老公不太好的事情，
一个是她在外面欠了大概有100个左右的债务，
并且他这个债务就他朋友说是名声不是很好，
是至有想赖账的这种想法，
就不太想还，
他家里是有几套房的，
是在北京，
但是在他爸的名下，
父己名下应该是只有一辆车，
他还有在外面可能彩旗飘票这种，
也是他的朋友说他给他外面这些彩旗嘛，
买礼物去买大几千上万的这种礼物都不还钱，
所以说是在他前的朋友对他也挺有意见的，
他跟我闺蜜说的是呢，
她现在在投资了大概100个做生意，
目前是在亏损的状态中，
就不怎么赚钱，
但实际呢，
也是其他朋友圈的这个反馈的话，
她可能只投了十个左右，
每个月能稍微少赚一点啊，
我闺蜜的情况呢，
她的工作还蛮稳定的，
一年可能能挣个二三十个吧，
他自己有房，
而是父母付的首付，
自己在还贷款，
我现在想问的问题就是，
第一是从法律的层面，
我应不应该告诉他这件事儿，
因为如果是债务，
婚前债务是不是他不知道，
就跟他。
没有关系的，
当然另外还是我也想咨询一下龙眉姐姐，
从但是看人生活的方面见不见议有告诉他这件事儿，
他这种情况，
因为他们结婚时间其实挺短的，
今年8月暂到现在没有几个月嘛，
觉得挺气的，
把这件事儿如果说他比如说决定要离婚，
或者说是您今天建议他怎么样做，
能够尽可能降低他的损失，
或者说有一定的经济的补偿之类的，
从感情方面和方面这个事儿得说一下你闺蜜是什么样的性格，
如果你闺蜜本身是一个识好歹，
本身是一个就是通情达理，
就真的是识好歹的这样一个性格，
就有可能走下一步，
那你闺蜜如果说小心眼儿也未必识好歹，
那你做这件事情可能会给自己招来祸端，
你闺蜜她人性格怎么样，
本人能力各方面，
我觉得她从工作方面还蛮有能力的，
自己学历也不错，
是985毕业的，
至少肯定不是小心眼的人，
我们俩的关系还不错，
我觉得她可能就是比较单纯，
可能她老公说什么她都信，
我就是不太清楚，
比如说我跟她说了以后，
也许她会我不希望她去跟她老公去对峙这个事情，
最后她不相信我去像望她老公这样，
我觉得也挺，
就是反而是好像破坏了他们的关系，
我觉得是这样的姐妹啊，
以我的为人和做事情的风格，
我做这件事情我可以预判有可能会失去这个闺蜜，
但是基于我的。
道德拘予我的良知，
就算失去这个闺蜜的话，
我也没有什么大不了，
我只是维持我自己心中的正义和我心中的善良和我心中的秩序，
这件事情可以干吧，
可以干，
我觉得我自己是有这种感觉的，
我觉得他家说这件事情会影响我们的关系，
但是我希望他知道，
不管他以后打算怎么做，
但是至少他知道这件事情可以提前给自己想想退路，
因为这个事情是欠债的事情哦，
确实是对一个人的经济影响还是蛮大的，
欠100万呢是吧，
他不是有几套房嘛，
所以他概念一下男方家庭条件是挺好的是吧？
对，
我看到评论区很多人都说让你别说这个事情啊，
江哥和刘星的事情大家都知道啊，
闺蜜帮另外一个闺蜜去解决感情的纠纷，
最后丧命的这个事情，
要不你借别人的口说也可以，
具体怎么说可以再考虑一下，
确实是看你跟闺蜜的这缘分生浅了，
这件事情没有对和错，
从保护你的利益的角度来说的话，
当然是不说，
但保护你吗？
是不是因为你说这件事情对你不会有一毛钱的好处，
不会有一分钱的好处，
只会给你带来一定的风险，
是不是从保护你的利益的角度来说的话，
我不管，
这是别人的因果，
如果这件事情发生在我的身上，
如果说是我的大学的闺蜜，
或者说是我高中的那个闺蜜，
遇到这样的事情，
我会不会说呢？
我可能会说，
因为我离得远，
我也不怕别人有什么风险，
这是第一，
第二，
我也不怕失去他们，
我也不怕他们说以后跟我不往来了。
怕明白了，
如果说我有底气能堡护好自己，
并且能承担失去他的后果的话，
对我觉得他个就可以对没事的，
从法律角度来讲的话，
你这边有什么建议吗？
给到他这个，
如果说是他婚前就欠了100万的话，
那么这个债务只要是没有用于夫妻共同的生活，
跟配偶是没有关系的，
他如果跟他存夫的婚姻关系持续时间更长了以后，
会不会导致他这个债务就需要他来帮他还了，
比如说他名下也有资产债，
婚姻关系的存续并不会转化债务的性质，
他婚前欠的这100万什么情况下才可能转换成夫妻共同的债务呢？
就是男方拿出证据来证明，
比如说他婚前借的这100万专门用于购买了共同的婚房，
购买了共同的车辆，
购买了家里面的家具家电，
在这种情况下是有可能转变成夫妻共同的债务的，
否则的话，
他们结婚的时间再长，
婚前的债务跟女方也是没有关系的。
明白就如果说明的话，
你，
你觉得假如我跟我闺蜜说了这件事情，
我应该怎么建议他去堡好自己的财产，
或者是交低损失，
你建议他怎么做，
比如说离婚还是怎样，
你不要开这样的口，
建议人家离婚，
就建议他保护好自己的财产就很好了，
守住自己的存款，
观察男方的负债，
跟男方的经济往来的时候一定要特别的注意。
比如说举个例子，
男方隔三差五的给女方转个3万五万的，
那他有可能到最后就说，
哎，
是我婚前的那100万欠款我转给你了呀，
就变成了夫妻共同的债务了，
这一部分尽量在经济上做到第一堡，
护好自己的存款，
避免这种婚前的债务转化为夫妻共同的债务，
好明白，
那其他还有什么问题吗？
其他没有了，
心好，
那再见啊。
其实有一个心理学上的东西和举个例子，
我有一段时间看到过一个评论，
这个评论是什么呢啊，
就是妈妈带着女儿去宾馆捉她爸爸的那个什么场面，
但是你知道这个女儿这辈子最恨的人是谁吗？
你们猜这个女儿最恨的人是妈妈，
她并不是最恨爸爸。
再比如说，
如果说你撞破了你闺蜜的老公，
在外面跟别的女人鬼混，
你把这个消息告诉了你的闺蜜，
那你的闺蜜有可能最恨的人不是她的男朋友，
不是她的老公，
也不是外面那个跟她老公乱搞的女人，
她有可能最份的人是你啊，
这个是心理学上一个很常见的一种现象，
就是我们如果说想要告诉闺蜜她老公在外面乱搞，
她老公怎么怎么样的话，
那我承担着这样的风险，
所以这就是我告诉刚才那个妹妹，
就如果你能承担失去这个闺蜜的风险的话，
那你随意，
记得点赞关注哦。